hey it's Kennedy here in Washington DC
there's been a lot of recent growth and
construction but one building in
particular may be sending a special
message to the federal government
located on V Street the building
directly faces the White House do you
think that building looks like a middle
finger oh haha that's crazy it totally
does right it do it really do it
particularly reminds me of the different
variations of new development new homes
around the area it's a middle finger
though right yeah yeah how did you say
it I kind of see it a little resemblance
little thing oh my gooey Oh a lot of
them take pictures you know they watched
a lovely you know every passenger on the
street you know they keep looking at
this building so it's a new invention I
think maybe but that's not really what I
thought of
he'd do it is another thing they was up
to something yeah yeah they was a data
plane do you think the guys fly in the
bird of the White House if he does if
that's the reason bandit that's awesome
if it is I'm down I'm down